bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
et comme les et bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie ne sera vue et car la quête du
graal trouver la chaussure parfait
penchons nous sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
jambes aujourd'hui dans l'histoire de
soulever la ballerine d'où vient-elle
comment la portée des professionnels de
la mode et de la confection de
chaussures vous expliqueront son
histoire saviez vous par exemple que
cette chaussure malgré en charmante
simplicité n'existe que depuis quelques
décennies
vous découvrirez ensuite quelles sont
les tendances du moment nos
professionnels vous aiguilleront avec
leurs conseils shopping
ils vous apprendront également ce qu'il
faut éviter à tout prix
enfin nous vous présenterons des modèles
de ballerines complètement extravagante
que vous n'avez probablement jamais vu
et qui ont fait fureur dans les milieux
de la haute couture et du design mais
tout d'abord à le voir ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
paris 7 au coeur de la capitale de la
mode que nous sommes allés enquêter pour
savoir ce que vous pensiez de la
ballerine
alors mesdames votre avis que c'est
confortable surtout être joli et ça va
surtout chez saison finalement un peu
moins en hiver mais voilà les gens mais
assez régulièrement
moi je ballerines entourent
circonférence aussi bien de contracter
que que habillez moi je trouve que ça
fait les deux quoi c'est bien
non moi d'aller souvent talent c'est
vraiment parce que je viens paris que je
sais je vais avoir mal aux pieds sinon
ses talons en toutes circonstances
quand on est petit les ballerines sa
tasse un peu quand même
donc pas de berlin
c'est super content
voilà
si j'ai envie de mettre une petite
touche un peu plus féminine je mettrai
des ballerines quand même mais très
rarement des talons rodez à la confort
moi ça va dépendre de ce que je vais
faire dans votre journée en fait selon
ce que je fais je consens confort et
quand je sors tu puisses à l'esthétique
moi je suis
[Musique]
vernis colorés imprimer les ballerines
nous en font voir de toutes les couleurs
on les trouve à tous les prix dans
toutes les matières certains modèles
s'embourgeoise même d'un discret petit
allons pour gagner de la hauteur des
marques ont même réfléchit à créer des
modèles pliables pour pouvoir les avoir
sur toi en permanence sans aucun doute
la ballerine fait partie des modèles de
chaussures qui font la mode des années
2000 voyons maintenant comment la
batterie nenê et comment la porter
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la ballerine vous évoque
alors qu'est-ce que nous évoque le
confort toujours bien évidemment mais
c'est vrai que la ballerine a été un
petit peu mise avec l'ars ces derniers
temps mais si la ballerine est bien
revisité bien accorder avec des côtés un
petit peu fou etc
on peut être à la pointe de la mode à
plat donc de gambader etc
on n'a aucun problème de talons si
vraiment les tableaux font peur c'est
vrai que la ballerine a énormément
d'atouts donc je vous en montrer une
assez funky
donc voilà comme je le disais là on a un
modèle de ballerines donc en 42 car on
va jusqu'au 42e on n'oublie personne
même les femmes qui ont des grands pieds
ça existe un ya de très grandes femmes
quand même de très petit bonjour
du coup ici on a un corps en écossais
avec un petit noeud à l'avant donc qui
s'appelle lisa en velours eden donc vert
sapin donc c'est un modèle hyper
original hyper tendance qu'ont mais avec
un tee shirt etc
on passe vraiment pas incognito et le
carton de cet été qui était un des
atouts des pieds de juliette c'est la
toile de jouy
voilà donc c'est une matière un peu
vieille vous savez on les retrouve sur
les assiettes aussi où les nappes de nos
grands-mères et ben voilà maintenant les
a au pied et on est hyper tendance est
hyper fashion juliette les tous les
jours grâce à nos petites ballerines
donc la ballerine est une bête de mode
exact exactement
can you
[Musique]
la ballerine est effectivement au coeur
de la tendance et elle ne se démonte pas
et ne se démodera jamais parce que c'est
vraiment une chaussure très confortable
facile à porter et pour tout aller et
c'est vrai que les danseuses étoiles ont
lancé la ballerine qui s'est vraiment
vulgariser maintenant tout le monde
portent des ballerines jeunes ou vieux
celle qui m'a le plus marqué c'est là
c'est la ballerine de danseuses bon et
après on les a faits en plusieurs
versions par rapport à leur confort mais
les ballerines de danseuse c'est vrai
[Musique]
c'est en 1930 qu'un australien passionné
pour l'opéra jacob bloc qui vivait alors
à londres créer un atelier spécialisé
dans la confection de chaussons de danse
son amour de la danse le conduisit à
chercher à améliorer le confort des
danseurs il nomma ce chausson la
ballerine en référence à son amour de la
danse et de la musique classique depuis
sa marque existe toujours
[Musique]
jacob bloc n'a pas inventé le terme
ballerine qui lui est apparue autour du
xvième siècle et désignait à l'origine
une danseuse professionnelle de ballet
en 1947 une certaine rose repetto décida
d'améliorer encore davantage ces fameux
chaussons de danse pour le confort de
son fils roland petit célèbre danseur
la grande valeur ajoutée par madame
repetto fut de développer une nouvelle
technique de couture de la ballerine en
cousant la semelle du chausson à
l'envers technique qui deviendra
universel par la suite à paris roland
petit de vinci populaire et par
extension
l'engouement autour de ces fameux
chaussons de danse fut si fort que l'
usage des ballerines touche à tous les
types de danses pratiquées
[Musique]
au début des années 50 c'est rené cathy
qui commercialisa au grand public la
ballerine dans une démarche de
démocratisation de l'usagé de la
ballerine à la fin des années 1950
la ballerine de vin presque omniprésente
dans le paysage audiovisuel et
cinématographique grâce à une jeune
actrice nommée brigitte bardot dans le
film culte et dieu créa la femme
[Musique]
ou encore audrey hepburn dans ces
ballerines faire à garder
[Musique]
les ballerines de marthaler de vraies
chaussures de ville et toutes les jeunes
femmes souhaitait remporter encore
aujourd'hui les ballerines tiennent haut
le pavé dans nos placards à chaussures
pour leur confort et leur style élégant
[Musique]
je pense que la ballerine se démode
jamais parce qu'il fait une toute petite
pied mais je pense que vraiment cette
salle vox il produit qui évoque
l'enfance une fille donc il y a le côté
tout eu pour certaines qui ont fait la
danse classique et pour d'autres il ya
toute l'élégance de l'opéra de paris
donc je pense que c'est vraiment ce lien
très fort avec univers à la fois
infantile ou sophistiqué dans ce qui
explique que c'est devenue une
incontournable
lebel rim qui m'a marqué le plus et
repetto mais pourquoi parce qu'il y à
une adn dans ce marquis linéaire c'est
un produit qui évolue réellement de la
danse la marque est totalement intègre à
ses origines
le pdg de cette société monsieur gaucher
est exceptionnel donc à la fois sur le
plan business comme humaine et c'est une
produit aujourd'hui que je dirais est
totalement alignée entre ce qu'il est et
ce qu'il va devenir
et c'est en adéquation avec son marché
c'est une très belle réussite répéteurs
pour moi la ballerine à idéal n'existe
pas donc en fait il ne met trois grandes
réussites de la vie c'était d'être viré
de mon cours de ballet quand j'avais 7
ans et j'ai toujours une très bonne
souvenir de ce moment qu'on m'a dit que
j'étais plus bienvenus et depuis tout
mon vie professionnelle et aux
professions entier c'est d'échapper une
malheureuse j'aurais du mal à dire que
j'en ai une qui est idéal
est-ce que la ballerine vous évoque la
ballerine c'est là qu'ils perdent début
de saison finalement que qu'on décide de
mal quand on sait pas quoi mettre qui
est confortable qu'on enfile avec eux
avec tous n'importe quoi tient je met ma
petite ballerine parce que je sais que
suis bien dedans parce que c'est
toujours des matières très très souple
donc l' avantage c'est que vont elles
entretiennent toute la journée et puis à
la fois aujourd'hui on arrive à faire
des produits quand même qu'ils sont
élégants qui sont en même temps un petit
peu flashy du fait que c'est simple ce
qui a pas de talent on est bon on peut
se permettre d'avoir des couleurs des
matières de jouer un petit peu sur ces
différents aspects pour avoir quelque
chose quand un petit peu plus pointu r2
plus tordant sinon nous la ballerine
c'est quelque chose qu'on refait chaque
saison on essaye de les revisiter avec
ba le fluo avec parfois des couleurs un
petit peu plus classique mais toujours
en essayant de mixer en essayant de
changer aussi le fait qu'elle soit
échancrée pour la rendre voilà un petit
pic féminine
la semaine nationale c'est extrêmement
important toujours une semaine
extrêmement souple parce que c'est ça
finalement qui fait qu' elle va jouer
puis en même temps qui sait prendre est
ici d un show c'est toute la ballerine
ne se démodera jamais la ballerine est
un éternel recommencement
il ya un moment où elle a été classique
on la voyait presque plus et puis ils
ont ça fait depuis deux trois ans elle
est revenue extrêmement fort et puis
voilà aujourd'hui ça fait partie
intégrante de notre collection
depuis des décennies on arrive toujours
à innover avec des mélanges de matières
de couleurs avec des semaines toujours
un petit peu plus innovantes
surtout en les initiant les rendre
encore plus confortable la fabrication
elle est vraiment artisanale nous on
essaye toujours dans nord dans nos
ateliers en italie d'avoir des produits
dans les meilleurs poterie est vraiment
de sortir un produit qui soit original
mais passe partout voilà c'est vraiment
ça qu'on cherche
[Musique]
je
on continue notre exploration de
l'histoire du soulier parlons
aujourd'hui de l'allier de notre confort
j'ai nommé la ballerine qu'elle sam n'a
jamais caché une paire de ballerines
dans son sac à main pour courir entre
deux rendez-vous à l'origine un
accessoire destiné aux jambes fuselées
les danseuses professionnelles
la ballerine est désormais présente dans
tous nos dressings de 7 à 77 ans que
l'on soit bcbg fashionistas ou encore
casual
quelle serait la ballerine idéal la
ballerine idéal c'est un terrain talons
plats confortable avec un cuir pour une
très grande souplesse est quelque chose
d extrêmement sobre je pense que je
pense que c'est une chaussure relaxante
pour femmes pour se soigner des
cambrures trop prononcé chaussures du
quotidien par excellence la ballerine
aurait a priori tendance à moins se
prêter aux expérimentations des
créateurs en tout genre trop simple trop
plate et pourtant certains créateurs
explore le côté petite fille le
caractère régressif de la ballerine et
parviennent comme toujours à nous
surprendre avec quelques idées hors du
commun
ainsi marc jacobs joue avec la sfi
arrondi de la ballerine qu'il décline en
forme de souris en variant les matières
voici quelques chaussures de sa création
plutôt mignonne non
d'une autre manière vivienne westwood
dont certains modèles furent élaborées
en collaboration avec mélissa travail le
caractère régressif de la ballerine en
l'associant à une matière plastique qui
n'est pas sans rappeler les fameuses
méduses de notre enfance mais toujours
avec la touche punk excentrique qui fait
sa notoriété
par ailleurs louboutin démontre de façon
remarquable que la ballerine tout aussi
être chic avec des modèles bijoux à
strass modèles aux formes et aux
découpes plus évocatrice de la femme
adulte tels que le bout pointu que l'on
a l'habitude de voir sur l'escarpin par
exemple en rupture avec le côté petite
fille communément associées à la marine
mais louboutin propose aussi un modèle
qui s'inspire des origines de la
ballerine avec un talon complètement
improbable qui rend hommage aux danseurs
travaillant leurs pointes
il y à fort à parier que seuls des
danseuses professionnelles saurait se
chausser ainsi enfin dans un tout autre
style prada conçoit des ballerines à la
couleur et au textile très doux qui
rappellerait presque des chaussons
prouvant que le principe numéro un de la
balle rim est bien le confort au
quotidien
[Musique]
le conseil du jour pour bien porter ses
ballerines alors bien choisir sa marine
c'est assez compliqué parce qu'on se
retrouve souvent avec des ampoules on a
mal aux pieds la semelle est trop fine
donc il faut bien faire attention
d'avoir une semelle épaisse pour ne pas
sentir tous les graviers qui vont se
placer sous les pavés
et puis également avec un petit talon
pour le confort de la marche et pour la
position et la posture pour ne pas avoir
mal au dos comme ça c'est la première
chose pour bien choisir ses ballerines
et ensuite dans la ballerine tous les
styles sont permis
on peut avoir des ballerines qui vont
être sobre avec voilà comme par exemple
ici un corps tout noir et moi j'ai joué
juste un tout petit peu sur la bordure
avec un serpent métal un peu vieilli
donc qui va avec n'importe quelle tenue
moins que j'associe généralement quand
je suis habillé tout en noir
voilà je mets ma paire de ballerines
hyper sobre ou alors avec un pantalon
noir ou un jean noir
on peut également avoir des ballerines
un peu plus funky donc comme celle ici
que je porte
voilà que j'ai fait en toile de jouy
avec des tissus un peu rigolo jouer sur
le contraste encore avec la bordure
faire des devis color et puis donc ça
ces ballerines l'été avec tous voilà
pieds nus avec un jean retroussé avec un
short avec une robe blanche avec
vraiment tout et n'importe quoi elle
elle s'adapte et puis enfin une petite
ballerine un peu plus hivernal en tissu
écossais ont là une petite ballerine
kilt alors là pour le coup l'hiver on
restera sur une tenue un peu plus sobre
quand on ose de la couleur et des motifs
sur la ballerine et on restera voilà sur
un jean sur un pantalon noir sur une
robe noire sur une tenue beaucoup plus
sobre avec juste ce détail pepsi sur les
pieds
alors je porterai une ballerine avec
avec un jean ou un slim c'est très joli
on peut par tessa ballerines en 2013
de façon vraiment très coloré on met des
ballerines maintenant dans toutes les
couleurs dans toutes les formes et dans
toutes les matières surtout pour moi une
malouine l'epa tendance donc c'est
plutôt henan contemporaine mais finale
content pour elle que je boude
je dirais pas contre pour la cliente
qu'il achète c'est pas cher qu'un
produit donc
amusez-vous prendre du coup leur faut
pas être ces fonds fait avoir une belle
rime pour 10 euros donc c'est le moment
de se faire plaisir
comment porter son ballerines en 2013
pour moi le meilleur endroit de le
porter c'est évidemment son sac à main
ou peut-être commune produit dans la
voiture et me produis d'appoint quels
sont vos conseils pour bien acheter et
porté se soulever disons que la
ballerine
c'est en même temps la chaussure du week
end on va dire et
finalement elle peut évoquer un aspect
plus décontract et puis après ça va
dépendre de la couleur si jamais on on
va vraiment on est six ans décide
d'aller dans dans de la couleur elle est
là d'un coup un côté très fantaisie
parfois même teenagers et puis si on
décide ensuite d'aller dans des choses
un petit peu plus pas été un peu plus
travaillé et bien justement elle peut
avoir ce côté quand même plus s'habiller
plus femme qui fait peur finalement
c'est une chaussure c'est comme un jeu
c'était va de 7 à 77 ans et c'est
vraiment la chaussure qui va tout le
monde celle ci tout dépend des matières
des couleurs
voilà donc récapitulons pour être au top
de la tendance avec vos ballerines
mesdames
oserez jouer sur les contrastes c'est
parce que la ballerine va avec tout que
vous ne pouvez jamais vous trompez en
été comme en hiver
la ballerine est votre allié confort et
sobriété al'inverse éviter les semelles
fine pour ne pas sentir les graviers et
ne pas abîmer vos chaussures trop
rapidement les modèles sans talons pour
garder une posture plus féminine et plus
soucieuse de vos articulations
la ballerine rime avec élégance discrète
et confort incomparable
elle est définitivement l'allié des
femmes qui veulent se sentir jolie sans
sacrifier le confort de leurs doigts de
pied elle a aussi un aspect régressif
délicieusement enfantin mais elle a
surtout su se moderniser
s'adapter aux tendances pour devenir un
accessoire à part entière de nos tenues
et s'éloigner des codes de la danse
classique
si je devais donner un conseil style
investissez dans la bonne paire de
ballerines noires ou colorés à bout
arrondi avec un bout de ce type vous
donnerez l'illusion d'avoir des pieds
plus court et avec un modèle très
classique vous pourrez le porter aussi
bien avec un jean slim qu'avec une
petite robe noire pour aller danser et
si vous n'avez pas peur de vous faire
remarquer choisissez un modèle à
l'imprimé animalier le léopard reste une
valeur sûre ou encore fluo toutes à vos
ballerines et à très bientôt pour la
suite d'histoires de souliers
en temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]